Russian leader Vladimir Putin invaded
Ukraine after a speech on February 24th
calling it a special military operation
within hours Air Raid Sirens were heard
over Keith people sheltered in subway
stations as Russian forces attacked but
failed to take the capital Western
leaders responded with economic
sanctions we are ceasing all export
permits for Russia and canceling
existing permits
the southern city of mariupole offered
Stark images of the Russian invasion
on March 16th a week after striking a
maternity hospital there was a Russian
Air Assault on a theater housing
hundreds of people from above the word
children was painted next to the
building by the end of March Russia
changed its tactics pulling out of Kiev
and focusing efforts in the eastern part
of the country known as the donbass
but as Russian troops were treated human
rights investigators revealed evidence
of war crimes in early April in the town
of butcha hundreds of civilians are said
to have been found in Mass Graves or
their bodies left in the streets many
showing signs of torture
as the fighting continued into the
summer a standoff over Ukrainian grain
supplies threatened world food security
by July 22nd a mediated deal sees their
release that month Western European
nations were concerned about natural gas
supplies as gas prom Russia's
state-controlled Energy company began
limiting exports via the Nordstrom
pipeline gas exports slowed down once
again on August 31st for several days as
gas prom cites scheduled maintenance
on September 21st Putin calls a partial
mobilization of 300 000 reservists
during that month Ukrainian counter
offensives gained back territory in
Northeast harkiv and Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinsky raised the country's
flag in the city of isium on November
9th Russian soldiers were treated from
her song we're going to be providing
Ukraine with Patriot missile batter four
days before Christmas zelinski made what
is said to be his first trip outside of
the country visiting Washington there he
secured U.S Patriot missile systems the
calls for Military Support continued in
the new year as Ukraine pushed NATO
countries including Canada to supply
tanks
and as the year anniversary approached
U.S President Joe Biden marked the
West's commitment to stand by Ukraine by
making a surprise visit to Kiev earlier
this week
Kyle Benning Global News